[Musique]
bienvenue non pas sur le plateau d' à
tallinn interdire mais chez moi
confinement obligé pour parler de
l'épidémie que nous traversons et pour
mieux la comprendre
je vais recevoir successivement par
skype spécialiste des rumeurs c'est
pascal froissart l'auteure de rumeurs
histoire et fantasmes dieu sait s'il y a
des rumeurs en ce moment vraie ou fausse
et je reçoive ensuite à un historien du
moulin à images c'est joël blanchard
l'auteur de la fin du moyen-âge qui
vient juste de paraître un peu plus on
parlera des épidémies de peste et des
conséquences qu'elles ont pu savoir
qu'elles ont pu avoir à la fin du moyen
âge et on va voir s'il ya des analogies
alors je me tourne tout de suite vers
pascal froissart bonjour pascal vous
êtes enseignant chercheur à l'université
paris 8
vous êtes auteur de la rumeur histoire
et fantasmes qui était paru chez belin
en 2010 et je me souviens bien
alors c'était pas une histoire ce n'est
pas un catalogue des rumeurs ce n'est
pas une encyclopédie des rumeurs c'est
une histoire de des théories de la
rumeur et et elles sont nombreuses
depuis un peu plus d'un siècle
maintenant que nous étudions les rumeurs
alors pour commencer est ce que
l'épidémie
une épidémie c'est toujours propice aux
rumeurs alors c'est propice parce que
c'est une crise
l'épidémie s'est jamais quelque chose
d'agréable c'est quelque chose au
contraire extrêmement désagréable et
donc on est dans une crise ont qui plus
est aujourd'hui d'inédites les mondiale
elle est d'une dureté incroyable donc là
on oui on peut absolument répondre par
l'affirmative à l'idée que les épidémies
créé les rumeurs ou en tout cas les les
favorise maintenant il faut s'en méfier
c'est à dire ce n'est pas parce que nous
sommes en période de crise qu'il n'y a
que des rumeurs qui circulent en fait
c'est tout qui circulent c'est toutes
les informations circulent de manière
décupler comme jamais on a même reçu ce
qu'ils ont quand même assez rare un sms
du gouvernement tous les tous les
citoyens français leurs enfants ou à peu
près
donc on voit que la crise est un moment
qu'on peut qualifier d'infos des milk
c'est cette année au logis ce métier qui
est qui et qui n'est en ce moment c'est
en même temps que la crise a
surgissement de milliers de milliards
d'informations y compris des rumeurs
c'est à dire y compris un certain lot
d'informations qui circulent de manière
virale de manière incontrôlée très
rapidement et qui frappe l'imagination
parce que elle s'oppose ou qu'on arrive
à les qualifier de fausses le problème
c'est qu'il ya plein d'informations en
même temps qu'ils circulent donc comme
tonton cas n'est pas trop trop les la
capacité réelle enfin et qu'on ne
qualifie pas de rumeurs qu'on va
simplement qualifié d' information
bizarre d'information à vérifier et en
fait c'est l'ensemble qui fait cette
info des mystères vu un surgissement
extrêmement brutale de d'information de
rumeurs de mensonges de manipulations de
fait qu news enfin tout tout tout cet
ensemble de mots qu'on a pour désigner
des bons des bribes de récits sur la
réalité qui reste à prouver parce que on
aimerait bien savoir ce que c'est que la
réalité la réalité d'une épidémie en
particulier des changeantes
est ce que ça vaut la peine d'ailleurs
différence entre les rumeurs les fausses
nouvelles les faits que news les
légendes urbaines les mythes les
théories du complot les caisses qui a
encore les yeux les bruits qui courent
aussi une différence entre tout ça est
ce que cette différence est intéressante
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux mettre tout ça
dans le même sac alors de mon point de
vue
les différences sont à la fois
intéressant mais à condition qu'on
reconnaisse que tous aient ces mots là
nous recouvre à peu près des réalités
similaire en particulier que ce soit les
légendes contemporaine et légendes
urbaines et les rumeurs les fêtes news
tous et toutes ces choses là on partage
volontiers les mêmes exemples c'est à
dire qu'on a rapidement des échanges de
comment dire de deux thèmes de motifs
même délire avec les blagues par exemple
les blagues les rumeurs les légendes
contemporaine tout ça c'est ce sont des
motifs un petit peut être nos logiques
un peu communautaire qui circulent il y
à des blagues par exemple qui se
transforme en rumeurs et inversement des
rumeurs qui se transforme en blague ou
voir des informations qui vont venir dix
ont donné du crédit à des à des récits
qui sinon serait de la pure fiction
donc oui il faut faire la différence en
particulier il ya des choses comme très
clairement le mou fait que nous
s'il apparaît là il ya 2 3 ans en 2016
dans le nouveau vocabulaire c'est à dire
c'est le mot fait que nous en
particulier en anglais c'est un vieux
moss devient vieux syntagme l'emploi
depuis longtemps mais tout d'un coup il
prend une actualité nouvelle
pourquoi essentiellement parce que un
acteur politique majeur dans la
communication mondiale qui n est donald
trump et son équipe et son équipe de
communication vont utiliser ce terme là
pour disqualifier le discours
d'opposition aux états unis mais aussi
pour disqualifier tous les médias en
général et donc le moof news
il apparaît dans un nouveau comment dire
nouveau contexte de défiance ouverte
contre les médias et aussi de défiance
qui se matérialise dans l'utilisation
des réseaux sociaux trump et utilisent à
l'équipe de communication de trump et
utilise énormément le réseau twitter
et donc c'est un en actes le la
démonstration que les médias classiques
les médias mainstream comme comme et
c'est souvent 10 sont en faillite d'une
certaine manière pour véhiculer la
parole comme gouvernementales alors le
mot fait que nous en fait il recouvre
tout ça il recouvre cette défiance et
cette utilisation des réseaux sociaux à
des
fin mai quasi à l'internât tive disons
alors que moins d'être alternatif c'est
pas n'importe quel réseau et l'équipe de
communication de la halte rome n'est pas
n'importe quel club de communication
bref on voit que donc le mot fait que
nous apparaît pour remplir un vide
enfin on n'avait pas encore n'auraient
pas encore de mot pour désigner ça
puisqu'on n'avait pas encore ce ce
discours-là de défiance aussi flagrant
aussi évident est donc bon le mou
rumeurs qui aa qui existait auparavant
et qui recouvrait relativement bien les
choses bien un peu plus postérieure à la
home ou rumeur qui a eu sa mode dans les
années 80 90
il ya eu une mort hawks qui au début des
années 2000 qui a recouvert un peu les
mêmes les mêmes idées le morro que ça en
fait qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qu'est
ce qu'il reflète en fait ils reflètent
l'émergence dans les années 2000 2010 2
en tout cas en france parce que le mot
hawks sinon c'est un mot qu'on utilise
un en anglais de manière classique mais
en français le moro qui veut simplement
dire canular est plutôt canular sur
internet recoud précisément l'apparition
d'une culture du troll sur internet une
culture du akl dudu une culture du
pirate lourds ou voire tout simplement
d'une culture communautaire du csac
actes du forum et et de tous et de tous
ces micro société qui se constituent sur
sur les réseaux dont quoi bon on peut
épiloguer mais en fait oui vous avez
raison le principal le lieu commun de
toutes ces dénominations c'est des
récits qui circulent de manière
apparemment incontrôlée mais je
j'aime bien le mot apparemment parce que
en fait il suffit d'un petit peu de
temps et un peu d'effort souvent
remarqué qu'il ya des fils rouges qui
qui qui balisent très facilement le
circuit des rumeurs des hawks et est
défectueuse est en fait c'est ça le
coeur de tous ces concepts là c'est
cette ce sentiment d'incontrôlable qui
est aussi dit mme
d'un maîtrisable de noms qu'on ne peut
pas compter le nombre de gens ne peut
pas compter on ne peut pas mesurer la
vitesse de tout ça et donc c'est ce
sentiment là qui probablement est à
l'origine de tout et de tous ces
concepts mais en même temps on se dit
que le confinement avec tes gestes
barrières la distance au moins d'un
mètre qui doit tout ce qui nous sépare
et en ce moment ça pourrait être assez
efficace justement pour contrôler alors
le bouche à oreille mais en même temps
il ya internet via les réseaux sociaux
qui eux sont considérés comme des sexes
et les raptors contraire de rumeurs
alors là on est dans une période où les
deux bâles os oui alors à ceci près que
vous avez dit effectivement que la
rumeur on se l'imaginent comme étant le
bouche à oreille comme le ragot les
commères d'entendre les villages non la
rumeur avait comme les comme nous elles
varient en fonction des supports ssr
nous ne sommes pas des êtres qui
choisissons nos supports nous avons à la
fois un téléphone à la fois des voisins
avec qui on cause à la fois nous avons
un crayon pour écrire des cartes
postales pour ce qu'il en fait le font
encore on a on a les moyens d'envoyer
des caisses que j'ai oublié des sms rien
apporté on peut on ne fonctionne pas
qu'avec un seul média en secret on ne se
réfrène part il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de et surtout il la rumeur cette
espèce de grande discussion collective
cette circulation devrait si elle ne se
cantonne pas un seul un seul médium seul
support elle elle traverse tout est
d'ailleurs c'est même assez fascinant
parce qu'aujourd'hui on va trouver donc
des rumeurs qui sont écrites sur des sms
et qu'on va retrouver en vidéo sur
youtube et qu'on va retrouver à nouveau
en jeu c'est pas d'une autre manière par
exemple à la fiction en cinéma il ya des
scénarios de séries qui vont s'inspirer
de tout ça et donc on voit que est une
sorte de circulation des motifs de 2
alors que j'ai presque envie de dire de
la fiction mais c'est en fait c'est une
fiction c'est pas tout à fait mais
quelque fois c'est la réalité
néanmoins ces récits l'un circulent et
ils circulent
effectivement
d'autant mieux qu'aujourd'hui on a
énormément de médiane à notre
disposition nous sommes tous désormais
affublé d'un téléphone avec une caméra
donc on peut prendre des photos on peut
les envoyer on peut les légendes et et
on sait par exemple de ce que moi
j'appelle les ré les images du moral
c'est-à-dire des unes des images qui
fonctionnent comme des rumeurs des
images virale ces images là il y en a à
peu près 30% qui sont totalement vrai et
saugrenues et qui circule énormément
il y en a 30 % qui sont totalement faux
c'est à dire ils ont été effectivement
travaillées truqués tout ce qu'on veut
mais il ya un gros 30% de l'image qu'ils
sont vrais en scène sans trucage mais
mal les gens des essais les plus
difficiles en fait parce que ça veut
dire que n'importe qui peut les faire
ces photos là c'est à dire il suffit que
je prenne une photo de delà d'un fleuve
en crue et que j'appelle ça l'inondation
à venir enfin la légende pose des
questions que à laquelle l'image ne
répond pas et donc on voit que ces
images qui circulent beaucoup en ce
moment et c'est la même chose pour les
images filmées
lorsque je me filme en selle fille dans
la rue je peux faire raconter plein de
choses ces images là il suffit de
choisir mon arrière plan là j'ai choisi
un arrière-plan qui éclaire plan de
confinement vous aussi peut-être inventé
des tas de trucs mais bon peu importe ce
qui est ce qui est important dans ces
histoires là c'est de voir que nous
sommes des êtres communiquant que nous
prenons tous les moyens de communiquer
électronique mais aussi la vie réelle
comme comment comme on dit pour
l'épauler les gens qui sont sur le trop
trop souvent sur les sur internet on se
restreint jamais quoi il ya pas moyen de
dire non je ne parlerai que par internet
où je ne parlerai que je ne ferais que
écrire aujourd'hui ça passe par tous les
médias on voit beaucoup de messages qui
commence par c'est toujours une
infirmière un qui tient d'un médecin qui
tient dash-l de service lors cette
assistante parlementaire qu'il tient
d'un député qui tient à midi
ce trait est en général tous nous
supplient de faire passer l'info ça
c'est un lancement de rumeurs mais
parfois c'est des vrais rue main c'est
probablement l'un des ressorts très
efficace effectivement de la rumeur
c'est le côté affectif ou communautaires
communautaire d'une certaine manière
c'est à dire je vais m'adresser à vous
non pas en tant que juste être résonnant
mais aussi comme mon ami comme quelqu'un
qui va être je sais pas douée d'une
pitié doué d'une un sentiment de
commentaires de responsabilité parce je
fais appel à des affects ça c'est sûr
que ça marche bien mais pour être
honnête si je veux vous convaincre de
jeu pas de contribuer à une cause x ou y
de verser 10 euros dans une caisse
quelconque je vais prendre les mêmes
moyens c'est pas propre à la rue ben
c'est pas propre à la au faux de pour
essayer de convaincre on va souvent
s'appeler par des petits noms on va
souvent offert du ham et tu es comme moi
tu fais partie du même milieu du même
monde fait de et si tu fais comme moi du
coup tu serais tu seras comme moi tu
seras dans dans la même dans le même
cercle
donc ça c'est un phénomène de conviction
enfin qu'on connaît de manière classique
c'est à dire que souvent dans les études
on distingue le monde de l'information
d'un côté qui est le monde
disons qu froid rationnelle médiatique
et le monde de l'opinion qui est le
monde de la conviction et qui est un
monde choho compliquée et qui est pas
tellement médiatique et qui est au
contraire extrêmement communautaire et
qu'on voit dans les réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire que lorsque je regarde mes
amis sur facebook ou les amis sur sur un
autre réseau snapo instagram
ça va être des gens que j'ai choisi moi
même c'est pas forcément les gens les
plus intelligents et plus si puisque ce
sont mes amis mais j'en ai en moi je
sais moi qui ai fait le choix est donc
lorsque je vais me retrouver à
l'intérieur de ce cercle là et bien fort
probablement je vais être d'accord avec
eux puisque je les ai choisi ce sont mes
amis
donc je finis par me retrouver à
l'intérieur d'un cercle d'amis qui se
renforce dans ses propres opinions
alors c'est biaisé dès le départ puisque
je les ai choisis et où ils m'ont choisi
aussi
donc on est tourné tous d'à peu près des
idées cohérente on appelle ça donc
quelquefois des buts de filtres aussi
quand c'est repris par la technique
c'est d'accord aujourd'hui les
informaticiens ont compris que ça
fonctionnait la même manière sur google
et sur facebook
quand je cherche une information et
billets vaut mieux me proposer des
informations que j'ai envie de voir
plutôt que de me proposer des
informations que j'ai pas envie de voir
donc maintenant il ya des algorithmes
qui créent et qui est qui et qui calcule
déjà un petit peu ce que je vais
attendre et qui vont donc me fournir en
premier des informations qu'ils
penseront être pertinente pour moi donc
ça crée des véritables problèmes de
konvict d'auto conviction s'il est
finalement je ne suis plus confrontés à
autre chose que de l'information et de
la de l'opinion qui met déjà familières
ou auxquels je suis déjà habitué et donc
c'est je suis dans un univers est terré
alors c'est ça qui est terrible les
parisiens par le parisien les
toulousains parlent aux toulousains et
donc on va se retrouver dans des formes
de ségrégation informationnel enfin dans
des bulles de l'information qui dès
desquels il est difficile de se
distinguer mais s 400 on voit dès que
les moeurs il fausse nouvelle etc etc
quel que soit le nom qu'on leur donne en
ce moment particulièrement combattue par
la télévision par radio parlée des
journaux il semble qu'ils sont de
viville ans et chaque soir is attention
attention
est-ce que c'est efficace c'est ce que
les arguments d'autorité qui sont
employés à son goût la de stress que
cette pour débusquer le cette vidéo qui
a été particulièrement virale qu'on sait
où on accuse l institut pasteur d'avoir
inventé le petit 19 ans en 2000 et en
2003 fois bon il y avait une confusion
notamment liée à d'autres corneilles et
russes qui ont existé
préalablement à celui ci et puis avec ce
qu'il était écrit inventé par tel
chercheur de l'institut pasteur
un virus inventé par un chercheur ça
c'est clair que celui qui sait sur ces
recherches qui ont abouti
cela veut dire qu'il ya inventer et à
vider dans un laboratoire d quoi qu'il
arrive
est-ce que les arguments d'autorité qui
étaient ces faux complètement faux
est ce que ça marche alors ça marche
sûrement sur les gens qui sont proches
de ces personnes là c'est à dire que ce
discours là il est situé au civil vient
pas de n'importe où il n'intervenait pas
de n'importe quel comment dire
l'énonciateur la personne qui parlait
dans cette vidéo la qui a été
effectivement très très partagés et
surtout aussi très commentée et ensuite
c'était pas n'importe qui s'était
justement pas un médecin s'était pas il
est très honnêtement cette personne là
ne disait pas ne se prétendait pas
autres qu'elle n'était c'est à dire une
espèce de citoyens éclairés comme un
porte parole d'un groupe de cinq
personnes enfin bref il y avait un petit
côté je vais vous convaincre par des
arguments rationnels
bon je pense que sarah convaincu ceux
qui étaient déjà convaincus en quoi il
était déjà convaincu probablement dans
le fait que on nous ment on nous dit
rien le gouvernement nous cache des
choses
bon bref une rhétorique qu'on connaît
déjà et qui existent et qui n'a pas qui
n'attend pas la crise pour ce jour pour
ce faire pour vous pourrez pour exister
pour sa entend en revanche quand on
quand on le dénonce à la télévision ou
au journal de 20 heures c'est là où je
me demandais ce que c'est efficace
ou est-ce que ça ne parte pas simplement
de la diffusion de la rumeur
ah oui c'est vrai oui moi j'ai inventé
le terme 2 diffuse réfutation c'est à
dire qu'on diffuse en réfutant en même
temps pour répondre à la question oui il
est absolument impérieux de 2,2 de
réfuter quelqu'un qui vous un argument
qu'il faut il faut pas laisser en
flotter comme s'ils étaient s'ils
étaient réels en même temps c'est ça qui
est assez tragique dans la lutte contre
les rumeurs c'est que on le sait depuis
fort longtemps
en ce moment je suis en train de
travailler sur les années 40 et je
m'aperçois que dans les années 40 y est
déjà exactement le même débat c'est à
dire pendant les années de guerre
on est en train de se poser avec mais la
question c'est qu'est-ce que je fais
face à la propagande qu'est ce que je
fais face à la roumaine
est ce que je la démens parce que c'est
essentiel de démentir le mensonge ou
bien est ce que je fais j'emploie
d'autres techniques de communication
pour éviter de démentir et en démentant
de diffuser c'est à dire la réfutation
on le sait on a même des chiffres là
dessus c'est le meilleur moyen pour
donner de la notoriété aux informations
qu'on peut démentir
et ça veut pas dire qu'on va diffuser le
mensonge
ça veut dire qu'on va diffuser
l'information douteuses et c'est ça qui
est tragique c'est que du coup on va
fabriquer du doute
en voulant démentir au lieu de démentir
et de fabriquer des certitudes on va
diffuser du doute c'est à dire qu'on va
aller au devant de gens qui n'ont jamais
entendu parler d'eux
par exemple cette histoire d'intention
de deux coronavirus et on va leur dire
non non non en fait c'est l'histoire de
l'inventeur c'est ça n'a rien à voir
c'est bien c'est l'inventeur d'un vaccin
n'est pas l'inventeur
oui mais moi si j'étais pas au courant
et que tout d'un coup on me dira à tout
autant non mais ça rien à voir un
porteur ça peut pas dire qu'on a inventé
le virus moi je vais commencer à en
avoir peur ou plutôt je vais commencer à
avoir des doutes donc la réfutation
c'est le meilleur moyen de diffuser les
doutes et en même temps on ne peut pas
ne pas en faire quoi donc c'est quelque
chose qui est compliqué qui est une
question de dosage est aussi une
question devrait communications
publiques communication de crise les
communicants sont habitués à cette
question là ils servent qu'il existe
d'autres manières de comment dire de de
fabriquer de l'opinion publique de
fabriquer une bonne information de crise
et donc il n'existe pas en tout cas que
le moyen de l'arrestation pour lutter
contre lyon demain ça c'est sûr que non
mais il faut le faire oui
malheureusement oui on est toujours
l'impression que la rumeur ne fait de
victimes que parmi les gens peu éduqués
est ce que c'est le cas a surtout pas
non surtout pas il ya des études de
savants qui montrent que la croyance
dans les extra terrestres les plus
belles et plus prégnante elle plus
importante chez les gens qui ont des
diplômés universitaires que chez les
autres
donc non ça veut pas dire ça ça veut
dire en revanche que nous avons un
regard sur la rue main
qui est un regard extrêmement comment
dire en surplomb condescendant nous
pensons que la rumeur d'abord sa touche
toujours les autres on va jamais dire
c'est moi qui vais je vais vous raconter
une bonne rumeur donc ça va pas on s'est
toujours un diagnostic a posteriori
qu'on va faire sur des populations qu'on
estime - estimable précisément alors ça
peut être dans en termes de classes
sociales
la roma s'est souvent chez les
prolétaires chez les employés se passe
chez les cadres mais tout ça c'est des
choses qu'on ne vérifie pas
expérimentalement c'est à dire quand on
vérifie comment circuler l'information
ou la rumeur ne circule pas de cette
manière là il ya d'autres circuits mais
bête mais en tout cas pas il n'y a pas
d'un côté elle choisit pas que les
femmes ou que les prolétaires ça
n'existe pas alors il ya peut-être des
tendances il ya des choses comme ça
c'est s'est intéressée de quelques dates
et défis des films sur la rumeur ça se
passe toujours dans des petites villes
voire des villages
c'est le cas de la paix à paris qu'à new
york
comme si à paris à new york et rumeurs
c'est le constat mais c'est le regard
que l'on a sur leurs souliers sur la
rumeur l'a fait que news la croyance en
fait c'est un regard qui est en fait
liée aussi à ceux qui portent le
diagnostic qui sont ces gens là qui font
qu'ils sont les scénaristes
ce sont des gens des villes tout
simplement qui sont les gens qui font de
la communication de crise sert à pas ce
sont des gens des villes aussi sont des
universitaires et les universités d'un
temps qu'elles sont dans les villes
elles tiennent en une sorte de moule
urbain à toutes ces théories
donc oui et par exemple le fait qu'on
ait appelé sa légende urbaine est aussi
assez parlant c'est que les gens de son
rural ça n'étonne personne et légendes
urbaines tiens comment est ce possible
que les dans les villes on puisse croire
à des choses irrationnelles ou un peu
étrange ben en fait c'est simplement que
la nature humaine est faite de croyances
nous avons ce n'est pas anormal de
croire il ya rien de mal à croire à être
superstitieux il n'y a rien de mal à
être croyant
dans un dur il rien de mal à être
croyant même temps je sais pas dans des
idéologies
simplement il faut pas mélanger les
registres certain moment où
effectivement il ya les les
il faut trouver des moyens de discuter
avec des vocabulaires comme attendu
comme un de la réalité est là
effectivement de la croyance doit
s'entendre sur d'autres procédures alors
on a inventé une ça s'appelle la science
on en a inventé une autre ça s'appelle
la justice
tout ça ce sont des puits y en a
d'autres mais des procédures qui
permettent donc de s'entendre sans
parler de ses croyances à mais comme
vous savez la procédure scientifique est
compliqué
comme vous le savez la procédure
judiciaire est compliqué s'entendre pour
savoir si monsieur ou madame est
coupable il faut aussi mais à 12 pour
savoir s'il est que pas vous parler et
c'est un vote qui est on décide c'est
pas c'est pas autre chose c'est pas une
je parle des assises
donc on voit bien que la réalité
judiciaire c'est quelque chose de très
complexe en fait et on peut on peut
sortir d'un procès en étant blanchi
alors qu'on est coupable c'est possible
et inversement on peut être condamné
alors qu'on est innocent donc la réalité
judiciaire s'est compliquée la réalité
scientifique c'est aussi très compliqué
là par exemple on a en ce moment un
débat national autour d'un traitement
alternatif du coc vide 19la avec la
chloroquine qui est à un antipaludéen
qui a raison qui a tort dans cette
histoire là les scientifiques eux mêmes
sont en train de s'écharper parce que
c'est compliqué parce que nous on a une
procédure scientifique standards qu'on
applique en temps de normes tant de
peine dix secondes
si on peut estimer qu'on a en tant de
guerre maintenant justement comme c'est
la crise est-ce que cette procédure
standard mérite encore d'être mise en
avant en permanence en ce moment c'est
la controverse à l'intérieur même de la
communauté scientifique est en fait
c'est plutôt bien
il faut pouvoir en discuter il
il serait rien de plus grave que d'avoir
quelqu'un qui dirait voilà la position
officielle de que j'ai décidé et non par
le parlement n'en parlons plus j'en ai
décidé donc on voit que toutes ces
procédures la race de rationalité sur la
réalité sont en conflit n'ont qu'à
valence avec les croyances avec les
superstitions avec le fait que le virus
mais comme il vient enfin de qui
provoque le commis 19 ne résisterait pas
l'eau bouillante bah oui mais je
déconseille par de l'eau bouillante
aussi ne s'est pas une bonne idée
enfin bref il ya déjà plein de choses
comme ça et puis et puis encore une fois
ces six jeunes si je diffuse enfin je
réfute
j'ai été frappé par exemple le
washington post au début de la crise
c'était un peu moqué du ministère de la
santé parce que ministère de la santé
avait renvoyé sur les réseaux une pub
enfin depuis une annonce disant
attention le nom cette union est une
fausse rumeur une faut une rumeur une
fausse nouvelle je sais pas ce qu'ils
avaient dit que selon laquelle la
cocaïne guérirait ducobu de 19 ha oui
mais personne ne le croyait
c'est une blague et donc le washington
post aux états unis avec jusqu'à et en
disant mais là vous vous rendez compte
que vous êtes en train de diffuser un
truc un peu risible qui plus est mais
vous diffusez c'est à dire il n'y a pas
personne ne le savait cette histoire là
donc là en réfutant cette information là
bas vous êtes en train de le diffuser
tout gouvernement que vous êtes
on pense toujours que ce sont les moins
éduquées qui qui diffuse des rumeurs que
ce sont par exemple les hommes de
troupes pendant la guerre qui diffuse
les rumeurs alors que les officiers
évidemment hui sable ne croient pas ils
savent donc ils ne défilent pas rumeur
il ya un cas intéressant où les médecins
eux mêmes ont diffusé une rumeur
c'était il ya longtemps maintenant mais
reste un cas emblématique des théories
de la rumeur c'est celle eux ce sont les
décalcomanies ou lsd qui était censé
frapper les enfants pour en faire des
drogués et puis les dealers des liquides
était raconté que les dealers distribuer
des des quelques beignets l'été pour
faire de nos enfants des des drogués en
puissance ça ça a été véhiculée par les
médecins ce sont les médecins qui ont
fait deux morts mais les médecins il
faut pas là
jeter la pierre ils sont ils sont
crédules comme les autres il ya des
médecins qui sont plus ou moins à temps
précis dans leurs annonces
il ya des gens qui ont effectivement
donc sur le cas que vous citez il ya eu
en tout cas une salle d'attenté dans
laquelle étaient affichés ce tract et
qui était un tract effectivement
totalement ont pas totalement faux mais
mais mais tellement flou est tellement
sans aucun lien avec la réalité
française que ça n'avait pas de sens oui
c'est vrai que ça va quand même pour un
médecin s'il vérifie pas ses sources
maintenant un médecin peut faire des
bêtises ça arrive là il se trouve que je
ne l'espère cela n'a pas causé deux
morts dont les légendes sur les vols
d'organes dans les pays du sud
là aussi ça a été diffusée
essentiellement par des cadres
supérieurs des hommes d'affaires qui
craignaient qu'un jour où les endort
mais qu'on leur vole leurs reins qui
aurait retrouvé qui leur a été ôtée pour
le pour le revendre ensuite pour le
marché d d d d organes tout ça
évidemment était une pure légion de mai
a été véhiculé là encore par des gens
qui étaient quittés très éduquée donc on
n'est pas à l'abri
ah non non non on n'est pas à l'abri et
7e c'est une l'éducation n'est pas le
seul moyen d'éviter de tomber dans un
faux stands pour on peut à la fois soit
crédules soit être simplement induit en
erreur
tout bêtement et l'éducation ne suffit
pas alors qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
faire une bonne information et être bien
informé
si c'est ça la question qui a en fait en
derrière la réponse est c'est compliqué
pour être bien informé d'abord il faut
avoir une bonne information à la
disposition et donc ça c'est essentiel
par exemple aujourd'hui de réfléchir à
un circuit par circuit par exemple de
financement de l'information dans les
pays occidentaux
actuellement il ya un bouleversement
depuis l'arrivée des de l'internet
surtout de certains acteurs de
l'internet
qui fait qu' il tout l'argent disparaît
des caisses des journaux pour apparaître
dans les caisses des moteurs de
recherche ou des certaines plateformes
de l'école communautaire donc là pour le
moment on a un problème de financement
d'information ça c'est le premier gros
problème qu'il faudra trouver auquel il
faudra trouver une réponse et comment on
fait pour faire de l'information sans
argent à mon avis il ya pas moyen il va
falloir aller chercher l'argent mais
ensuite il ya un deuxième plan à cette
question aussi de comment être bien
informé donc non seulement il faut avoir
d'abord il faut aussi avoir de la bonne
éducation d'abord le fameux sens
critique l'esprit critique etc
j'ai énormément de collègues et moi-même
qui travaillons là dessus mais on n'a
pas beaucoup de baguette magique on a
pas on sait pas très bien faire c'est on
n'a pas une recette pour trouver le
moyen de jeu c'est pas un véritable être
un instrument qu'on mettrait dans une
information pour savoir quel degré de
vérité est là ça n'existe pas alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que le meilleur moyen c'est de fabriquer
de l'éducation et ça je crois vraiment
et c'est aussi un métier dont je parle
trop de nos mollahs mais je crois que
l'éducation est le meilleur remède mais
pas une éducation
comment dire matérialiser dans un cours
d'éducation à l'esprit critique mais une
éducation générale c'est à dire qu'en
maths aussi donné de l'éducation
l'esprit critique à partir du moment où
on dit bah t'es sûr qu'un plusieurs il
ya 2 2 c'est sûr quand même si tu tourne
pas dans n'importe quel univers c'est
vrai donc en histoire évidemment qu'il
faut poser la question en littérature
aussi on peut poser la question donc en
bref c'est bien l'éducation qui est à la
source de cet esprit critique mais il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas un programme ya
un mook ya pas une une un cours qui
permettrait ou un livre qui permettrait
les méthodes de trouver enfin la vérité
parce que si on l'avait ce livre ma vie
serait beaucoup plus simple
on en mangerait plus rien à faire on
n'est pas bien
merci pascal froissart je rappelle que
notre livre la rumeur histoire et
fantasme est paru chez belin on se
retrouve juste après une pause avec un
historien cette fin d'historia du
moyen-age on continue par les députés
[Musique]
que l'on se retrouve maintenant avec
joël blanchard qui est historien
spécialiste du moyen-âge vous venez
publié la fin du moyen-âge chez perrin
alors le moyen âge est une période qui
est hanté par l'image des quatre
cavaliers de l'apocalypse et parmi ces
quatre cavaliers il ya la peste les
autres ce sont la guerre la famine et
les bêtes font le voyage a connu
plusieurs épidémies de peste la plus
célèbre sans doute la plus meurtrière
c'est la peste noire qui est arrivé en
france en 13 147 13 48
est-ce qu'on est un bilan de sa
mortalité la mortalité elle est
effroyable et si l'on prend les chiffres
donnés par les contemporains par deux
parfois ça par exemple ça atteint un
tiers voire la moitié de la population
européenne qui a été frappée par sept
par cette épidémie et en comptant
naturellement pas simplement de la peste
noire est en place mais aussi les autres
formes de peste et les autres lames de
fond d'eux qu'ils se sont naturellement
que l'on a plutôt long du 14ème du 15e
siècle il n'y a pas qu'une seule place
plusieurs peste en 13.47 348 la grande
peste est aussi plus tard au début du
xvème vers le 14 129 et ensuite à la fin
du xvème dans les airs et 14 180 donc on
a plusieurs lames de d'épidémie de
manière d'ailleurs qui n'est pas très
homogène et avec des délais qui sont eux
aussi pas très homogène
alors ce qui est là il ya une énergie
possible c'est qu'à l'époque les
contemporains décrites les chariots de
mort qui passe tous les soirs et on va
mettre les cadavres en ce qui concerne
paris c'est au cimetière des innocents
ça correspond à peu près à ce décompte
assez morbide que l'on fait aujourd'hui
tous les soirs des morts désaffecté on
sait aussi que les apprêter août dont
elle n'est pas le nombre
talent puisque on ne pratique pas le
dépistage mais le nombre de morts lui on
le connaît et ça ressemble un peu ça
ressemble un peu et là encore il faut se
se fonder sur le témoignage des
contemporains surtout des des écrivains
qui écrivent et au jour le jour des
journaux qui habitait paris et en
particulier l'un qui est assez connu que
j'en devenais qui a écrit une chronique
et qui raconte en effet cessé ses
chariots pleins de deux cadors parfois
500 quotidiennement que l'on amène que
l'on amène aux innocents soutien des
innocents c'est une vision extrêmement
macabre naturellement et c'est le sur
l'ensemble du territoire on a parfois
des idées des chiffres considérables je
prends par exemple le témoignage d'un
autre chroniqueur qui est le vrai jo de
paris
alors c'est dans la deuxième période
dans la première période du xvème siècle
il faut compter à peu près 70 % à 80 %
de la population en normandie qu'il ait
quitté été frappé par la peste
ce sont des chiffres ce sont des
chiffres considérables
on voit bien que les épidémies
aujourd'hui tube donc moins qu'avant et
heureusement
à l'époque on ne sait même pas commencé
à se transmet en 7 1 me dit que on croit
que c'est dans l'air voilà on ne connaît
pas l'agent infectieux de cette époque
l'heure on connaît bon les médiévaux
savez identifier deux formes de peste la
peste qui est
la baisse de 1,8 milliard ya enfin
bubonique celle qui se manifeste par des
bus bompard d un déni today et l'autre
peste une autre passe tu n'as pas de
plumes honneur donc les médiévaux font
ces distinctions mais ils ne connaissent
pas un agent infectieux c'est à dire que
pour eux la peste elle est dans l'air
pour ainsi dire ce sont les vapeurs
précieuse ce sont les l'atmosphère c'est
ainsi que d'une certaine manière on est
con on est contaminé
mais on ne connaît pas la contagion
d'homme à homme
c'est quelque chose que l'on ignore à
cette époque là sauf peut-être il ya un
médecin le médecin du pape qui lui
semblent up connaître cette cette forme
de contagion mais qui n'en parle pas
comment se protège ton alors alors on se
protège en évitant justement ces lieux
qui sont comme on dit à cette époque la
paix se se sont on évite par exemple je
cite là aussi un chroniqueur de l'époque
qui est le mot jeune paris qui raconte
que les femmes et hommes aristocrates ou
bourgeoise évident d'aller dans les bas
parce que pour éviter justement ces
phénomènes de contamination par l'air
c'est donc une une forme de assez
irrationnel peu scientifique
d'explication de ce phénomène
on fait à l'époque le lien entre entre 3
de cavaliers de l'apocalypse la presse
pour la di la guerre c'est la guerre de
cent ans la famine
évidemment qui est une des conséquences
de la guerre aujourd'hui on pourrait
dire qu'on fait le lien avec le 4e
cavalier les bêtes sauvages puisque
l'origine du cordat virus c'est ça les
marchés de ce sont les marchés de
viandes sauvages qui ont lieu en chine
notamment avec les chauves souris on a
parlé aussi de pompeux la la c'est le
quatrième qui avait elle est absente de
du moyen-âge le lien il est fait entre
la peste et la famine bon c'est logique
mais encore c'est surtout le lien qui
est fait entre la peste et à la guerre
parce que il faut pas oublier que nous
sommes en pleine guerre de cent ans donc
la guerre c'est un état endémique ce
parce que les as du monde et les
déplacements de deux hommes d'armes à
travers les campagnes qui chasse les les
paysans vers les villes sont des
éléments effectivement de contamination
très important oublier que le c'est
surtout un phénomène global à la peste
et donc le lien avec la guerre et effet
en effet d'une certaine manière par
cette mobilité à la fois militaire et
sociale que l'on observe à la fin du
moyen âge l époque on parle de punition
divine c'est quelque chose qu on n'a pas
encore entendu aujourd'hui enfin pas
tellement il est entendu en tout cas moi
c'est en effet la raison essentielle
l'explication essentielle qui est donné
c'est une punition de dieu
c'est une explication religieuse à
laquelle comment réagir face à ce sont
des processions ce sont des pèlerinages
de manière a pour ainsi dire et évacué
exorciser éliminé c'est cette
contamination
ce sont aussi des des flashs élan qui se
déplacent c'est flagellant qui sont une
forme de taux punition en fait c'est se
flageller pour finalement se purifiée du
péché là
l'amalgamé fait ainsi entre lon la peste
et la religion sous la forme d'une
punition divine qui sur une punition de
dieu pour les péchés des hommes les clés
flagellant à l'époque se promène dans
les villes se donnent des coups de
fouets dénonce une partie de la
population
est-ce qu'on a un équivalent aujourd'hui
il ya on a nos sièges et lent
aujourd'hui
non on a passé sept équivalents mais on
a quand même des tentations comment
dirais-je très très mauvaises qui est
par exemple de viseu choisir des boucs
émissaires
au moyen-age les juifs 1 sont persécutés
voir massacrer parce que on les suppose
qu'ils ont infesté des eaux ou qu'ils
ont enlevé une idée puis et cela suscite
des réactions extrêmement violente que
l'on observe dans toute l'europe alors
un peu moins dans le sud de la france
parce que là il ya les autorités le pape
rende ezzor est et demandant à ce que on
empêche de le persécuter les jls mais
ailleurs c'est ccdh effrayant ce sont
des véritables massacres qu'on a ce
témoignage est tout à fait
extraordinaire du genre venelles de ce
chroniqueur qui dit que des femmes
juives afin d'empêcher que l'encens
françois contraint à vos bâtons jetés
leurs enfants dans le feu avant de s'y
précipiter elle même dont il y avait une
espèce de de fureur contre le contre les
juifs que l'on observe surtout dans le
nord
reprenant le maillot angleterre un peu
moins dans le sud où ils sont un peu
plus épargnées mais qui sait mettre au
crédit d'un d'un chroniqueur comme je
redevenais de deux d'extrémistes un
scepticisme par rapport à cette croyance
comme quoi les juifs où m
revenu mais les populismes reste que bon
c'est cette étude de ce site une
situation absolument effroyable
c'est une conséquence d'effectifs de la
peste est ce qu'on connaît l'époque des
mesures de confinement est ce qu'on
parle déjà de quarantaine mais le
confinement lui même ça existe non il ya
eu point de vue médical alors là le
moyen-âge n'avait pas d instruments d
analyse il n'avait pas des moyens de
communication que nous avons aujourd'hui
il y avait ces croyances bon très peu
scientifique dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure il y a quand même quelques
mesures d'hygiène
on a des ordonnances au sujet de
l'hygiène dans les villes
mais la faculté de médecine et sans
moyens ne sais pas pour faire quoi que
ce soit et il la passe n'a été d'aucun
secours
d'un point de vue médical et du point de
vue du de la solution de ces
contaminations
à l'époque il ya tout de même le thème
du retour à la campagne vous l'avais dit
la peste c'est surtout dans les villes
on vient de vivre deux siècles environ
des sorts des villes en europe
au moyen-âge et c'est le sait le thème
du décaméron le célèbre livre de beau
catch est adapté bien plus tard au
cinéma par pasolini
ça commence par la description de la
peste et ça raconte le départ
d'occurrence il confinement à la
campagne pendant dix jours de cette
jeune femme et trois garçons le dk mon
n'aurait pas existé sans la peste
exactement n'a pas se sert de décor à ce
cette fiction assure ici de moka ce
qu'il a écrit quelques années après le
très peu d'années après le la patinoire
on le disait en 13 soit 55 des 350 2 et
se sont en effet cette jeune fils les
textes de jeunes filles et trois garçons
qui quittent florence ou celi la peste
pour se dépasser extra muros en un lieu
où chacun quotidiennement à tour de rôle
raconte une histoire dont le thème est
choisi par un roi ou une reine effective
et là on voit effectivement que la
littérature est un puissant direct à un
puissant dérivatif à 7,1 cette
mélancolie et a7 à cet effroi c'est peur
qui qui qui sévissent à cette époque là
il y a
également pétrarque qui dans son ouvrage
sur la vie solitaire recommande eux de
quitter la ville et ses ennuis ces
problèmes et de se retrouver à la
campagne pour se ressourcer c'est
également aussi pour le bien de certains
intellectuels qui part cela craint pas
une posture
voilà donc il ya effectivement quelque
chose d'un peu contemporain enfin en
citant cette évocation lors dans cette
espèce de fuite de déplacement mais avec
naturellement des effets qui sont
majeurs puisque on dissimule le virulent
en se déplaçant
et quelle affluence c'est ce que ça sur
la peinture alors sur la peinture une
très grande influence
je serais tenté de reprendre une
expression de la mission locale qui
disait que jusqu'à 350 on ne savait pas
représenter la mort parce que la mort
n'existait pas et c'est vrai qu'à partir
du tracé de 350 donc au moment de la
peste il ya eu un changement assez que
assez conséquents dans la thématique
pictural et la passe a beaucoup marqué
la peinture on est passé le thème ou
d'illustrations assez positive à un état
qui sont vraiment mobile ou maka que
l'on pense par exemple à la danse
macabre que dont on a une idée des
représentations dans un an dans toutes
les langues toutes les églises un peu
pension également à des tableaux
certains sont restés à l'ap que je pense
en particulier aux au thème de la mort
de brian may qui a été composé de lui un
peu après vers 15 162 un siècle après
que mais que ce qui touche à la fin des
temps à l'apocalypse et est un thème
extrêmement nourricier pour pour la
peinture et très certainement que la
pasta markets
déterminante dans ce nom dans ce courant
et dans cette influence à l'époque tout
le monde est touché les nobles comme les
paysans comme comme le clergé bien
entendu vous l'avez dit l'église
organise des processions des rituels
mais évidemment elle est impuissante
est-ce que ça va avoir des conséquences
là encore cette impuissance de l'église
cette impuissance de l'église on peut
émettre l'hypothèse de c'est vrai que
les les sacrements
les processions religieuses aucune dans
l'esprit des gens du moins ce n'est pas
écrit un effet thérapeutique ou
thaumaturgique lorsque l'on observe
c'est ce que le liseur et chroniqueur
c'est qu'il n'y a jamais eu autant de
morts que les processions et pèlerinages
et donc il y a comment dirais-je une
unité de la croyance des jo est un peu
mise en défaut et on peut inférer de
cette impuissance de l'église royer le
fléau
on peut inférer une critique ou une
protestation qui donnera peut-être y
aura peut-être des effets dans la suite
avec la réforme
on sait que bon lui car par exemple ni
la présence réelle de du christ dans le
dans l'eucharistie donc une espèce de
défiance vis-à-vis des sacrements et de
toutes ces manifestations religieuses si
on dit toujours que cette peste noire
revenait déjà de chine
à l'époque alors est-ce que c'est albert
et on allait sur aujourd'hui ce serait
les cavaliers mongols qui à l'époque
régné sur la chine qui n'aurait apporté
en europe
oui elle vient de ghazi c'était des
mongols qui disséminent et 7 ce virus au
moment du siège de caf aquitain un port
un comptoir chênois sur la sur la mer
noire et ensuite la peste été
il est disséminée jusque dans l'arc
méditerranéen
d'abord à messine puis ensuite à
marseille au début de l'année 35 48 et
puis ensuite c'est naturellement
déplacer et disséminés dans l'ensemble
de l'europe
c'est à peu près le chemin que connaît
cette grande peste ce qu'il faut savoir
aussi c'est que c'était quelque chose de
tout à fait nouveau pour les gens parce
que la dernière peste que l'on avait
connu cet espace d'une pastille city
hall où existe le 6e siècle dont qui
s'est passé six siècles entre cette
première mi-temps de postes et la grande
poste et donc pour les gens quelque
chose de tout à fait nouveau et cette
image condat des mongols assiégeant une
ville et catapultant des cadavres de
pestiférés est ce que c'est une légende
de l'époque
est-ce que les mongols ont vraiment
inventé la guerre bactériologique au
fond on ne sait pas mais en tout cas
c'est raconter par départ des
chroniqueurs il est plus vraisemblable
que c'était le un virus infectieux un
agent infectieux comme la loi ou la puce
il y avait mais l'image de ces corps
infecte et catapulté par dessus les
lémurs de kafa pour contaminer les
actions est une image extrêmement forte
et qui participe de cet imaginaire de la
paix ce qui traduit en même temps la
sensibilité extrêmement vive aiguë des
gens jeunes blanche à on a l'impression
que au fur et à mesure qu'on avance dans
le temps perd la mémoire la mémoire de
l'athlète la grande peste de la peste
noire est restée très vive à 100 en
europe l'an table
tout le monde sait les enfants
aujourd'hui savent qu'il y avait la
peste en europe au moyen âge en a bu
beaucoup moins de souvenirs de la de
l'épidémie de grippe espagnole au
lendemain de la première guerre mondiale
qui m'attend de faire des dizaines de
milliers en or ça sert tout péter
billets en partie et plus récemment la
grippe de hong kong en 1969 qui fait
quarante mille morts en france un
million de morts en europe
on l'a complètement oublié comment
est-ce que vous expliquer qu'on oublie
civic qui s'est passé récemment
et alors qu'on garde en mémoire ce qui
s'est passé il ya longtemps je n'ai pas
d'explications précises mais ce qui est
certain c'est que le l'ampleur de la de
la contamination le nombre de morts est
extraordinaire dans la déflation
démographique qui a accompagné cette
grande peste est également les
conséquences économiques
effroyable le désordre social
pensez aux litiges ou procès pensez
également dans le domaine de l'éducation
l'a surmontée d'une année la
surmortalité des clercs donc les enfants
n'étaient plus en classe
il ya vraiment attachés à cette image de
la peste médiévale une manière
extrêmement violent extrêmement brutal
qui peut expliquer que l'on ait gardé en
mémoire cet événement et il y a aussi
les illustrations il ya des peintures il
ya tous les témoignages livrés
structuraux qui sont là pour nous le
rappeler
ce qui est aussi très étonnant et là bon
c'est si beau monde est pas sans se
déplacer un peu c'est les parallélismes
qu'on peut établir entre ce qui s'est
passé en 14ème et 15ème siècle et ce qui
se passe maintenant il y a comment
dirais-je il ya plusieurs choses qui ici
me frappe
il a d'abord ses peurs et ses peurs
irrationnelles
ça c'est un premier point
le deuxième c'est le
les croyances les croyances qui se
multiplient et les fausses rumeurs des
fausses croyances la violence également
les effets de cette de cette
contamination et je pense en particulier
au massacre des juifs ou aux flashs et
non bon ce sont des images extrêmement
forte
l'image du bouc émissaire est également
la faillite de l'état et de l'église
d'une certaine manière qui quand on lit
un auteur comme jean de roquetaillade
quitte un prophète un illuminé du 14e
siècle mais qui a été beaucoup lu quand
tu quand tu lui poser la question de
savoir quand est-ce que jusqu'à quand
allait durer cette peste
il répondit le temps n'est pas encore
venu il faut que le monde soit
complètement bouleversé paille à cette
idée finalement que qui est attachée à
la peste l'idée de catastrophe
il est d'un but 2 2 d'un malheur
extrêmement extrêmement violent et maker
et m me semble-t-il rester dans l'esprit
et des contemporains yal'idée aussi que
le monde va être purifiée quand il en
sait ce qu'ils entendent aussi par par
un bouleversement que lieu plus rien ce
sera pareil ensuite que ce sera un
nouveau monde c'est une idée qui
aujourd'hui prospère alors pour terminer
quelles ont été les conséquences de la
peste
alors là sur le plan économique par
exemple parce que ça c'est quelque chose
qui nous effraie considérablement je
crois qu'à l'époque les prix ont doublé
1 carrément après la peste les prix ont
doublé
les terres sont
on était comme d'ailleurs être récupéré
par les ceux qui ne sont pas morts donc
il ya une le témoignage d'une source
d'une forme de cupidité d'avarice qui
transparaît dans ses textes
et puis il ya surtout cette idée
aujourd'hui bon ce sera peut-être un
nouveau monde
mais quand on interroge les
contemporains quelqu'un comme je
redeviens qui nous disent ce sera encore
pire c'est à dire que les effets de la
de la poste se sont peut-être pire
encore que la passerelle même et ça je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
assez frappant lorsque on y ses auteurs
c'est médiévaux c'est cette crainte de
la deûle après et ça s'est vérifié
ça s'est vérifié le monde de passer
christelle manière parce que la guerre
de cent ans a continué sa a été
absolument effroyable et on a ce que je
vis un peu de la fin du moyen-âge n'est
ce pas une atmosphère extrêmement sombre
à la fois plein de mélancolie et ayant
même temps bon n'attendent qu'une
attente effectivement de l'apocalypse de
la fin des temps qu est ce qu un
sentiment instamment religieux est lui
aussi très violent le moyen-âge
pourquoi avez vous choisi est ce que
c'est ça qu'on s'aime attend que ça
n'était plus la période sombre qu'on se
plaisait à décrire au 19e siècle
est ce que c'est une période de de
lumière comme mons on a tendance à le
penser aujourd'hui
oui c'est une période de contraste c'est
à dire on est resté sur l'image d'une
fin du moyen-âge crépusculaire
extrêmement socket une image romantique
d'ailleurs qui a été colporté par les
romantiques mais ce qui est intéressant
est justement on en a parlé à travers le
témoignage je sais écrire un c'est à la
fois la capacité de réfléchir de rebond
et
et l'ouverture d'un espace public c'est
à dire que l'on commence à se poser des
questions il ya tout un bouillonnement
d'idées d'humanisme qui commencent à
apparaître des figures de
d'intellectuels extrêmement forte
par exemple dans le jeu ces prédicateurs
qui prêchent justement au moment de 2,2
de la peste et sugar d'intellectuels qui
peuvent être des hommes et ce également
des femmes on pense une femme
extraordinaire et à l'étranger à qui
christine de pisan anaky qui a écrit des
ouvrages politiques
donc c'est à la fois une période sombre
parce que il y en à peine s'il ya des
divisions et les factions il ya la
guerre franco anglaise il ya la famille
du roi mais en même temps une espèce
d'aspiration et de prise de conscience
qui se manifestent justement parce et
ses prises de parole non le grand
intellectuel et ce sera à mon avis
l'image de cette femme moulinage à la
fois sombre et éclairer une image très
contrastée
et puis il y ait la décence il y à la
naissance du capitalisme ou l'oubli
toujours en france 1 où on s'intéresse
plus volontiers aux guerriers aux rois
ou paysans qu'aux marchands pourtant les
marchands les banquiers ça commençait à
ce moment là le capitalisme n'est au 14e
ou 15e en italie du nord
et ça ça peut être une sacrée la
commission ça va être une grande
évolution il ya deux feux est vraiment
important dans cette fin du moyen-âge
c'est en effet ce que vous dites du
capitalisme et du développement d'une
société mercantile et également le
développement
de la diplomatie d'invention la
diplomatie telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui c'est à dire finalement des
moyens de communication qui se
développent des interactions entre et a
de plus en plus nombreuses qui sont
propices justement à l'expression
d'idées nouvelles à ce bouillonnement
d'idées dont je parlais précédemment
merci gel blanchard je rappelle que
votre livre la fin du moyen-âge vient de
paraître chez perrin merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain euro
[Musique]